JEFF POSNICK: Hi, everybody.
My name is Jeff Posnick.
I'm a member of the YouTube API
Developer Relations Team.
And thanks for joining us
for this week's "YouTube
Developers Live." Today, we're
going to be focusing on a very
important topic, and that's
using Google+ identities and
how that interacts with the
YouTube API and things
developers should know and even
some things that users
should know.
So we have a special guest with
us today for the show.
That's Sherry Listgarten.
Bring up Sherry.
Hi, Sherry.
And Sherry is a product manager
responsible for
overseeing the overall
integration between Google+
and YouTube.
So thanks so much for having
us on the show.
We definitely have
the expert here.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: I'm happy
to be here, Jeff.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
So for folks who aren't familiar
yet with what we've
started making available, can
you talk a little bit about
what you can do with your
Google+ identity and your
YouTube channel and maybe a
little bit of the motivation
behind the overall project
in making this available?
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Yeah, sure.
That's a really good question.
So let me give a bit
of background.
So before we started doing all
of this linking between
YouTube identities and Google
identities, a typical YouTube
user would have a
Google account.
And it would have
two names on it.
It would have sort of a
Google name, which was
used in Google context.
And it would have a YouTube
name, these strings, the user
names, which is used in
a YouTube context.
And that's kind of a problematic
situation to be in
for a couple of reasons.
So there are a couple
of problems
that we want to solve.
And I'll give some examples.
A very basic example's the
YouTube names are very
restrictive and very ugly.
It has to be this string.
It has to be unique, nobody
else can have.
And people have these kind of
strange YouTube user names,
many whom would rather just
use their name or use
something like My Great Videos
or something like that.
But a bigger problem is that if
you have one name that you
can use with Google and another
name that you can use
with YouTube, what happens if
we have a feature that uses
little bits of Google and
little bits of YouTube?
And we want to build-- we have
tons of great features like
that, where we want to bring
the best of Google into
YouTube and the best of
YouTube into Google.
We have no idea what to call you
if you have a YouTube name
and a Google name.
And it's not just that we don't
know what to call you.
But there's potential of
a real privacy leak.
A lot of people are happy having
these two names linked.
A lot of people are not happy
having these two names linked.
And we simply don't
know what to do.
So we can't do anything.
And so we decided that we wanted
to get out of this
state where you have two names
on one account and get into a
state where you have one sort
of Google-wide identity per
account, so one name
per account.
And you can use that
name everywhere.
So maybe you want to start using
your cool YouTube handle
that you really like on
other Google products.
That should be fine.
Or maybe you want to use your
Google name, which is Jeff
Posnick, a nice normal name,
and you want to use that on
YouTube instead of
JPosnick5678 or
something like that.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure, sure.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Again, sort
of the main reason why we're
doing this is to build
cool features.
So maybe you want to integrate
Calendar with YouTube so that
you could schedule an event
and things just show up.
We couldn't do that without
this single identity.
We know what to call you.
You guys may be familiar with
the private share [INAUDIBLE].
Google has fantastic
sharing capability.
YouTube not so much, everything
is public.
But you can now take a video,
if you've merged, and share
privately and it's a terrific
feature-- with circles or
individuals.
JEFF POSNICK: I definitely have
been using that a lot for
home movies and things like that
that I don't necessarily
want to be broadcast to
the entire world.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, so that's
an awesome integration.
And I know that previously we
kind of went through a process
where we started requiring all
YouTube channels be linked to
just a Google account.
It was not necessarily a Google
account that had a
Google+ identity,
Google+ profile.
Correct me about some of the
terminology if you have a
preferred nomenclature
for this.
So how is this type of
integration different than
that earlier effort to make
sure that everything was
linked to a Google account?
SHERRY LISTGARTEN:
Yeah, totally.
So, like you said, the first
part was to get everybody to
sort of link YouTube accounts
and Google accounts, which is
really important.
And that means that now Google
knows that these two
identities belong to the same
person and the same account.
And we can help you out and
build some things using that.
But it doesn't tell
anybody else.
The rest of the world has
no idea that these
two things are linked.
And that is really, really
important for some people.
So the difference is that
the account linking--
get onto one account that
we did before--
was private, was Google knows
this, YouTube knows this, but
nobody else knows it.
And what we're doing now is your
public-facing identity,
trying to unify you're
public-facing identity so that
there's only one of
those per account.
And it can access all the
services and we can
[INAUDIBLE] these really super
cool new features.
We're announcing another one
coming up at VidCon in a week.
I mean, we have a ton of cool
stuff that we're building once
we get everybody on a single
identity per account.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
OK, so that certainly makes
sense for the motivation.
And I know that one thing that
kind of adds an extra wrinkle
that we announced a little while
back but has certainly
gained more traction is the
ability to not just link a
Google+ profile that's
corresponding to a single
person but to link a Google+
page identity
to a YouTube channel.
Can you talk a little bit more
about why we are letting
people do and why folks might
want to use a Plus page
instead of a single
personal account?
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Sure.
So, again, our goal is to have
all YouTube users having a
single Google-wide identity
per account.
If they want to have two
identities, one which is Jeff
Posnick and one with just Cool
Jeff, that's fine too.
But they're going to be on
two separate accounts.
These accounts may be linked
to each other.
So what is a Google-wide
identity?
I keep talking about this.
Well, OK, so Google identity
is implemented by Google+.
And Google+ has two forms
of identity really.
They have something called a
profile, which corresponds to
kind of a real world person.
It's usually the name on the
profile's the name that you're
commonly known by.
It corresponds to
an individual.
But there are a lot of YouTube
users who have kind of
business or brand that they
want to maintain.
It's not their name.
But it's something like
Mystery Guitar Man or
something like that.
And that's not a good
use for profile.
But that is a good use
for a Plus page.
So what does a Plus
page give you?
First of all, it lets
you use any name, a
business or a brands.
There's no kind of constraints
on it.
But it also gives you
lots of really
cool management features.
So, for example, a lot of people
right now, they have a
YouTube channel.
They need some help
managing it.
Maybe they go on vacation.
So they share the password to
their account with all of
their friends.
That's kind of a dangerous
thing to do.
What you can do now with a
Plus page is you can have
different people managing your
Plus page and helping out with
your channel without sharing
your password.
And so that's a really
nice feature.
In addition, if you have a
couple of channels, you can
manage them all from a single
Google account.
So you can switch back and forth
between them and manage
them all at once.
So there's a lot of nice
features [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF POSNICK: Which is great.
I mean, I know a lot of people
probably just have a bunch--
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Management
features for people.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
I know a lot of people probably
just have incognito
windows open and are like, oh
no, I need to sign into this
account to manage this channel,
or I need to have--
maybe they're using
Chrome profiles.
And being able to do it all
from a central account
switcher and just go from one
channel to another really
makes my life a lot easier.
We do this on our team for our
YouTube Dev channel, for
instance-- our YouTube for
Developers channel.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN:
People love it.
The other thing is if you're a
creator and you're sharing
your password, we've asked
creators, we said, who has
access to your channel?
They're like, I don't actually
know anymore.
I've shared it with
these roadies.
I've shared it with my
friend's grandmother.
They don't even know who
has access any more.
If you do it in the new way, you
have different managers.
You know exactly
who has access.
You can revoke access.
You can grant access
It's really nice.
You don't have to change your
password and lock everybody
out all at once.
These are really, really
nice features, really
important to creators.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And a lot of that we also get
as part of using OAuth 2.0,
which we'll talk about a little
bit later when we get
into maybe more of the technical
portion of the show
where we talk about how
developers need to kind of
react to these changes.
So that's great.
OK, and we mentioned that
right now you can link a
personal or individual's Google+
or Google identity to
a YouTube channel and also
the Plus page identity.
So that's great.
And, I mean, do you see that
we're going to get to a point
somewhere in the future where
100% somewhere close to 100%--
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Absolutely.
So we have well over half of our
active users linked in a
single identity situation,
which is just fantastic.
Plus pages are taking off.
I mean, people are so excited
about having access to them,
especially our creators
and partners, but
lots of other people.
And we hope to have almost
everybody in this single
identity, one identity per
account situation by the end
of the year.
Again, if you have want to have
two identities, that's
totally cool.
But they're going to
be linked together.
They're not going to both be
on a same account anymore.
They're going to be linked
accounts instead.
JEFF POSNICK: And that's
definitely something that
developers need to
keep in mind.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: So end
of the year, Jeff.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, well, that's
a very ambitious goal.
And I certainly hope
we get there.
And it's something
that developers
need to keep in mind.
I mean, we're not talking about
some esoteric thing that
only certain applications might
need to worry about.
We're going to get to a
point where this is
going to be the norm.
And there are important
implications for developers.
So I actually wanted
to dive in a little
bit about that, unless--
is there anything else, Sherry,
that you wanted to
point out coming from a product
point of view before I
start talking about--
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: No, we're
really excited about this.
And it is important for our
developers to know that,
again, over half of our users
are already in this state.
And it's really climbing
rapidly.
I think it's over 60% now.
I mean, it's just going
up every day.
JEFF POSNICK: Right.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: OK, so on the
YouTube Developer Relations
Team, we're doing our best to
make sure that developers are
aware of the best practices that
they should be following
to deal with these accounts
in a graceful way.
So I wanted to point
out a few resources
that we have available.
First of all, there's a blog
post from last month.
And pull that up
on the screen.
It's called Google+
page identities
and the YouTube API.
This is a, hopefully,
comprehensive overview of
things that developers
need to know.
And it goes through some of the
same best practices that
we're going to be
covering today.
So if you don't watch through
this video, you want a
reference to refer to later
on, definitely check
out this blog post.
There's a link in this
video's description.
And the link is part of the
GDL page for this show.
So you could get to the
blog post via that.
And the blog post points out
a few important things.
One of the most important
takeaways is that if you are a
developer and you are using
OAuth 2.0 to allow users to
authorize access for your code
to make changes to the account
or read information about their
account, folks using
OAuth 2.0 don't really
need to do very much.
There is a small edge case where
if you're using OAuth
2.0 as part of some Android
applications right now, things
might not work exactly as
I'm describing here.
But if you're using OAuth 2.0
as part of a web application
or an iOS application right now,
you'll actually get the
scenario where the user who's
going through the
authorization [INAUDIBLE]
gets to determine
which channel--
and that's associated with a
Google identity-- but which
YouTube channel they would like
to authorize access to.
So there's a little
screen shot here.
But let me show you in practice
what this looks like
using our Google
API's Explorer.
So for those not familiar, this
Google API's Explorer is
a good way of trying
out different API
calls from a web interface.
And it supports OAuth 2.0
natively as part of this,
which is always nice when
testing things out.
So this is our standard call in
version 3 of the data API
for getting information about
the current user's channel.
It puts in part snippets and
the mine equals true
parameters, which means just
give me some basic
information, the snippet of
information about the current
user's channel.
Mine equals true means we
need to be authorized.
And I do this right now.
I'm not authorized right now.
I get back this 401 unauthorized
error.
So that means I need to go
through the OAuth 2.0 flow.
Click over here, just say that
those are the scopes I want to
grant access to.
And because I have two different
channels that I have
access to by virtue of having
my own personal channel--
that's my Jeffrey Posnick
channel associated with the
Google+ identity for myself.
And then I happen to be the
manager of this Google+ page,
+YouTube Dev, and that page
has an associated channel,
YouTube for Developers.
So we detect that
automatically.
We know which Google account
you're currently signed in to.
And we'll know that, OK, there's
two possible channels
that I might want to
grant access to.
So if I choose this one, you'll
get back an OAuth 2.0
token that's associated with
my Jeffrey Posnick channel.
If I choose YouTube for
Developers, you get back an
OAuth 2.0 token that's
associated with that.
So for these purposes, let me
just actually choose YouTube
for Developers.
And I'm going to go down and
click Execute again.
And you'll see you're getting
back information for the
YouTube for Developers
channel.
So this is really important.
That little interstitial, that
little channel picker that
came up, you get
that for free.
And once you get the token back
after the OAuth 2.0 flow
completes, that token will
behave just like any other
OAuth 2.0 token.
The authorization is associated
with one specific
channel at that point.
You're not getting back an
OAuth 2.0 token that has
access to both channels and
you have to set special
delegation parameters or
anything like that.
That's not how this works.
You will get back a normal
OAuth 2.0 token.
Your code, at this point, does
not have to do anything
special to figure out which role
the user wants to act as
because they already expressed
their intent as part of the
OAuth 2.0 flow.
So that actually makes it really
easy for developers to
kind of seamlessly make use of
this power and not have to
worry about dealing with the
scenario where there's
multiple channels.
So that's great.
And that's kind of the
best practice if you
are using OAuth 2.0.
And all our modern APIs
do require OAuth 2.0.
You're in good shape.
So, unfortunately though, we
have folks out there who are
still not using OAuth 2.0.
And it might be because they
have legacy applications using
the older GData API.
And that case, there are
different ways of doing
authorization--
AuthSub, OAuth 1.0.
Or probably the most common is
ClientLogin, in which there's
a username and password
supplied.
So we, obviously, are concerned
about properly
supporting those
scenarios too.
And we have a couple of
different things.
And some of this is things that
your actual end users
need to do.
So as a developer who might be
watching this show, you might
get questions from
your end users.
You can point them to
these resources.
In many cases, unless you're the
developer and you're also
authorizing as your own account,
these are going to be
things that are more relevant
your end users than to you.
But there are two main ways of
working around these problems.
And these are the options
over here in this blog
post that we detail.
One of which is to
use this advanced
account settings page.
And let me pull up that
page really quickly.
And this is at
youtube.com/account_advanced right now.
And there's a section
over here--
Signing into Older Apps.
It will let anybody change the
default value when they log in
with their Google account
username and password, going
through ClientLogin,
for instance.
This will change what
page they act on by
default, more or less.
So if I said, any time I go
through the ClientLogin flow
as my Google account username
and password, even though I do
have a channel associated with
that Google+ identity for my
Google account, instead I would
like to act as YouTube
for Developers.
And that's just kind of a way
of establishing a global
default that works for all
older applications.
So that's one thing that
your users could do.
The other thing that gives
people a little bit more
control and this might be
because, let's say you have
three different possibilities
and sometimes you want to act
as one, sometimes you want to
act as another, we actually
have a way of assigning login
credentials to specific
Google+ pages.
And that's at this link over
here which will take you to
this help center article.
And this will basically generate
a email address
that's not actually
used for email.
But it uses kind of the
identifier and allow you to
assign a password associated
with that email address.
And when you enter those
credentials, you will be
authenticated as a
Google+ channel--
sorry, Plus page
backed channel.
So if you have a legacy
application that will only
take a new username and password
and you need for that
application only, so maybe you
don't want to change your
defaults, your global default,
if you need to log in you can
set the that credentials.
It's not going to be
the nicest email
address in the world.
It's a little lengthy, and there
might be some strange
characters in there.
But it will be a work around
for your users.
So ultimately though, as a
developer who might be
watching this show, what I can
tell you is that please
upgrade to OAuth 2.0.
Please make the switch.
If you're using one of the older
authorization protocols,
switching to OAuth 2.0 will
give you a number of
advantages and not the least
of which is it'll be good
login experience for users who
have multiple channels to
choose from.
So there's another thing to keep
in mind that we covered
in this article, which we also
linked to in the description
of this YouTube video so you
could check it out yourself,
and this is working
with channel IDs.
This is something that's a lot
more relevant as we see more
and more especially new channels
that might be set up,
which just have their Google
identity associated with them
and don't have a legacy,
I call it a
legacy YouTube username.
It's kind of like the
traditional, unique identifier
that would be given for
any YouTube channel.
So it is now possible to create
those types of channels.
There's no legacy username.
And really the only way of
uniquely identifying those
channels is with the specific
channel ID that we return as
part of our data
API responses.
There are a lot of folks out
there who have older
applications that maybe have a
database that makes use of the
legacy usernames as primary
keys in them.
Perhaps you have some reporting,
and you're keeping
stats about each channel
somewhere.
That certainly is a legitimate
use case.
But you need to be aware of
the fact that not every
channel moving forward--
and certainly this is
the case already--
has a legacy username.
And we really do recommend that
everybody switch to start
using channel IDs as their
unique identifiers internally
within their applications.
That will allow you to work
with any older channel.
Every single channel
has a channel ID.
So it's not just these
newer channels.
And we have some helper methods
in both the data API
version 3 and also ways in the
data API version 2, if you're
still using that, to translate
between an older user name and
get back a channel ID.
So please check out this article
that I also wrote and
follow all the recommendations
there so you don't get burned
by these channels that don't
have legacy usernames.
And there's one more best
practice that we touched on a
little bit in the blog post, but
I wanted to make kind of
perfectly clear and really bring
to the forefront because
it's very important.
And this is more of a user
experience best practice.
There is always the possibility
for confusion now
that there are multiple channels
that a user might
choose from.
And maybe somebody inadvertently
sees that
channel picker and clicks on the
wrong channel and doesn't
realize it initially.
So we really are strongly
encouraging developers out
there who have user-facing
interfaces--
maybe it's a web page, maybe
it's an installed
application--
to display the channel title
and the profile image
associated with the currently
authenticated user somewhere
clearly in your application and
hopefully also have a log
out link to let people log
out if they see, oh, I
inadvertently authenticated
or authorized
access as this channel.
I want to click this log out
link and switch instead, go
through the flow again, and
choose a different channel.
So that's a very important
best practice.
We know not every application
does that right now.
But please keep that in mind as
something you might want to
do moving forward.
So those are the best practices
that I wanted to cover.
And going back to Sherry, is
there anything you feel I
should've mentioned, anything
that left out.
Or does that seem to cover it
by way of best practices for
developers out there?
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Yeah, I think
that was really good
using OAuth 2.0 and showing
the user who they are,
especially when they're
writing.
If it's a consumption activity,
maybe it's not so important.
But if they're uploading a video
or writing a comment,
it's really important
that they know who
they're doing that as.
So I think that that's
really important.
I think we really appreciate
your team supporting our
developers so well in this
effort, new APIs and old APIs
it's really great.
JEFF POSNICK: Well, thanks.
And we know that this is
something that is kind of a
little bit of a brave
new world for
developers out there.
So, hopefully, the information
in this video and the blog
post and the guides--
and we're happy to field
questions on Stack Overflow
with the tag YouTube-API.
We've started seeing more
and more people
asking questions there.
But we're happy to help folks
through this migration.
And I think Sherry mentioned at
the beginning, it's going
to open up a lot of great things
for users out there.
And that's the most
important thing.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: Not just
at the beginning--
forever!
JEFF POSNICK: Right.
You mentioned it at the
beginning of the show.
It is a universal improvement
for everybody
til the end of time.
So great.
So thank you so much for
joining us, Sherry.
Just a couple of plugs at
the end of the show--
as always, Developer Relations,
Google Developer
Relations is hiring.
So if you think that you might
be a good fit for our team,
please check out
developers.google.com/jobs.
I also wanted to plug--
I mentioned briefly-- we have
a channel dedicated to these
YouTube-related videos.
That's youtube.com/youtubedev.
But there's also the main Google
Developers channel,
which if you're just watching
this somewhere and you're not
already subscribed to that,
I'd highly recommend
subscribing.
And that's
youtube.com/googledevelopers.
And please check that out for
more information as we make it
available in cool new videos
in upcoming weeks.
So thanks again, Sherry.
And that's it for this week.